[Music]
even in 1968 the Fox logo took 15
goddamn seconds proving this logo was a
long-standing Hollywood tradition of
bullying audiences and that completes my
final report until we reach touchdown
Aryan touch my crew in for the long
sleep I'll be joining so Heaven's Gate
why didn't ask to make the spacecraft
soundproof apparently even in 1968 it
was an acceptable future for astronauts
to be smoking a goddamn cigar in the
shuttle family even in 1968 was an
acceptable future for astronauts to
place their cigar right next to
flammable raw material okay wait this
guy woke up from crowd sleep left a
voice message for mentioning the people
who set him on this mission are all
surely dead suggesting he's been in cryo
sleep a while moles around a moment then
puts himself back into Kraus we don't
have that right
I guess NASA didn't give this movie
permission to use their name so the
filmmakers took this newfound grade of
Liberty to switch to letters nearly two
minutes of opening credits that do
nothing for nobody
thankfully these crabs sleep pods open
with the ship encounters a problem
something 2016's passengers couldn't
even get right Stewart that is one of
the weirdest cuts in all the history of
film editing ah 1960s on centered zoomed
high 1960s horror movie screeching the
only reason this hibernation chamber is
cracked and the others aren't is because
it was that motherfucker Chris Pratt
wasn't it also on the late 60s when the
only major female human character is
casually killed before even having a
line in fact they didn't even need to
hire actress for this role just used a
prop goddamn other than the two weird
minutes of opening exposition this
movie's opening 25 minutes are actually
fantastic disorienting without
explaining too much long takes with
little to no dialogue somebody's way
better than you remember it being is
what I'm saying two sins off yes okay
thank God I mean it's earth but you
don't know that so here is this is
luckier you just Christ landed on a
planet with air you can breathe baby
15 seconds of this guy giving
play-by-play about the inevitable ship
sinking you didn't have time to read the
tapes this will be a convenient out for
the movie so that these astronauts won't
suspect they're on earth but somehow it
doesn't have time to check the basic
information
I guess answer really is a discount NASA
that food water amounts right three-day
your emergency bailout of your spaceship
metallic backpacks have three days of
rations that's it do I even bother
packing emergency ration pack
and apart from that you look pretty
chipper for a man who's 2,031 years old
this dick waited until now to tell these
guys the year like whole raft ride over
here he said man I can't wait to spring
this fact on these assholes I'm
wondering that's my motto it's a fact
Landon with the fake background behind
me right now well there's no life here
we've got just 72 hours to find it what
did you just say no seriously let's
spell it out again for posterity there's
no life here we've got just 72 hours to
find it
notice this flag god help you if you
don't hey guys so like I was saying this
looks like the western United States
right doesn't look like the western
United States surely they would have no
planet they were going to with the Sun
that looks suspiciously like ours even
if they didn't know the exact location
and even if they didn't have time to
check the tapes as much as I love this
movie
and its first 20 minutes it's maybe the
most Grand Canyon porn film ever made
right outside of those three connected
Brady Bunch episodes at least this
Boulder realizing the movie needed some
action decided to start falling at this
very moment to give the astronauts
something to do other than imitate the
Lord of the Rings the hold of you cloud
cover tonight a strange luminosity yet
there's no moon how do you know did you
just land even we're supposed to believe
they've seen nighttime here the movie
shield none of it everything about this
planet is warranty better light a
cigarette
also with precious cargo space for this
important mission they still send
cigarettes shot to even set up a guy
addicted to cigarettes let alone supply
to feed that addiction that way there's
only room for three days of rations they
stop here to smoke and argue and they
somehow all completely avoided the shade
of the rock they stopped behind
seriously all these cars are in direct
sunlight right now chase dodge somehow
got a half mile lead during this
conversation line what's immediately
killed the first sign of light that we
see take that stuff yo movie
overestimates my tolerance for watching
people walking glad they made it but
they climbed down these rocks to get
here which is hilarious I mean I'd skip
it too because it's literally impossible
but love the movies optimism how
unobservant do you have to be to not
even be looking for danger
three catalytic aircraft that's easy to
say when you don't realize you're the
crow in this situation yes I know you
hear water but you're on an alien planet
at least in your mind he weirded out by
weird please
the Jerry Goldsmith really do the score
for this movie guys it gotta be
astronauts also I'm kind of wondering
how the scene would have played out if
their female colleague had lived
beginning to think that is the only
reason she died so that these dudes
could skinny dip in peace also just to
make it men's women and frolicking and
wooing together just two days after
crash landing and having the crew mate
die totally doable right here folks
hello what's happenin here I'm not
judging I just wonder if they have time
for this finally and only for the sake
of propelling the plot these guys see
the natives that have been following
them for a long time also why do they
steal their clothes it's a summer camp
the planet Jorge is only interested in
who's stealing their stuff to the point
this movie can keep a G rating and keep
us from seeing Charlton Heston also this
movie is rated G another rating system
doesn't come in for a few more months so
this movie was rated afterwards but the
MPA saw this and said general audiences
I want that MPAA back this shot is
brought to you by your local
optometrists looking to make a quick
buck the crew conveniently finds stuff
to cover up their naughty bits all in
one place so this whole movie doesn't
have to be blocked with rocks trees and
comically placed bananas so all that
with the running hiding and stealing
natives was just an elaborate hello the
land when the hell did he get a fruit
and why is he not sharing now the middle
guy has a fruit too but throw and toss -
any fruit - these curse not at least
they haven't tried to fight it you think
you're 2,000 years ahead in time and on
an alien planet and you're going to make
the comment like this instead of
something like holy the aliens on this
planet looks just like we do and look
more or less human I think they're mute
you've been watching them for 30 seconds
asshole what a weird thing to say I
shall meet with that one over there the
first reveal of the apes being
accompanied by this music awesome once
in removed why is it cutting down all
the coal the humans are running away
through the core Apes walking slowly and
chopping down on the corn should lead to
the humans escaping though this movie
will claim the opposite this is
extremely inefficient netting doesn't
even wrap around these people by the
time it's done and that just looks like
a minor inconvenience then you have
these assholes who go by two-man teams
to catch one person I mean figure out a
plan guys didn't slaving the human race
for years and this is some cut-rate I'm
an animal psychologist that's all we
have no authority expositional arguing
come on speak come on speak there is no
reason I can think of why after the Apes
took over their planet humans forgot how
to speak again at this point the movie
we don't technically know the desert but
final reveal sure makes
so the movie scene seemed a lot more
stupid doesn't it he keeps pretending he
can call only because he was shot a
throat earlier does his speaking ability
take a while to manifest you know what
they say human see human do
har-har hilarious but not really
hilarious reversing a primate based
idiom is hilarious but not really
hilarious
George tries to grab zeros pen and
notepad in an extremely insane
animal-like way because of course he
does but never wants to zero who
believes humans can act like the Apes do
try to get the pen and notepad to him
anyway even on a whim because I guess
pens and notepads are in scarce supply
in thirty-nine seventy eight and she
probably has a ton of unfinished
tic-tac-toe games written down so would
want to lose those also the standard
prison guard weapon here is apparently
an oversized crutch this guy was
credited as super starving begging arms
guy and he was paid exactly twenty
dollars for his work but he clearly gave
it his all hot ape action jeweled read
something in the sand and while I know
that he can't talk it's absolutely crazy
he can't tap a cage or do something to
get zeros attention during this no the
for no other reason the plot starts to
wipeout what George wrote the Sam just
punishment for fighting in that cage
will be to put you in another cage
that'll teach you thankfully for I guess
the extras budget this jail appears to
be completely empty during this scene
how to make a female ape fall in love
with you in less than two seconds if
you're Charmcaster Oh Wayne Indiana
woohoo shout out to Fort Wayne where I
live for five years of my youth go you
Huskies well not Huskies probably IPFW
is Mastodon which admittedly doesn't
roll off the tongue as well but does
better fit the motif of the joke
possibility and yet the science ignorant
ape still somehow took over earth at
some point a century or more after
humans discovered flight come on are we
supposed to believe that these hyper
intelligent Apes haven't figured out
paper airplanes these assholes are
talking about brain surgery but even the
simplest idea of flight never cross
their minds
also this Apes society has learned the
joys of ink pens and paper which also
suggests they have other modern things
like the paper mill and machinery that
can cut the paper not to mention all the
complexities of producing an ink pen I
know this movie needs a couple things to
get the story going but I'm not giving
you latitude will be set the ape evolved
from a lower order primate possibly man
Louie just thinks it could reverse
everything even evolution this guard
comes in with a leash or some rather
than a lacrosse stick thing that
everybody else uses yeah
he has found peace in heaven jerk eight
nets continue to be insanely bad at
their job and all that in the last
several minutes is now a meaningless
distraction after he gets caught again
thanks for that movie
I enjoy being teased come on seriously
oh wait now he's pretty good
Christ long JC Shyamalan Heston's balls
cam thankfully these Apes have a humans
museum which he fortunately wandered
into our accident also even more
thankfully there are somehow now only
two dudes chasing him instead of
mannequins this movie uses live extras
here to pose as the three cavemen next
to our hero and if Yuri watch their
footage they are hilariously not still
so they made a museum exhibit out of his
fellow crew member that's fine but the
speed at which they did it considering
the crash was just a few days ago it's
astounding anything for a great visual
though I guess this is bad eh I'm sure
but he's also not even aiming at George
he's clearly shooting to the left have
Apes figuring out that they're capturing
tools are yet they seem to all break or
magically spill off a little to no
effort because the filmmakers decided to
shoot this next shot the dramatic way
this is the one that will actually
capture George cages stinking paws off
me you damn dirty ape it looks like
running around like a fool around this
village gave George's voice back or was
it because he briefly walked through
that church it's a miracle
that being said I'm also removing two
sins for this moment because its iconic
Brown also because Rise of the Planet of
the Apes later perfectly mirrors the
moment with Caesar yelling no at the
primate refuge and I kind of have high
powered fire hoses in this a future but
they don't have central heating they're
stupid apes did I tell you about Stuart
and there was a lovely girl she was to
be the new Eve you see when three male
astronauts love one female astronaut
very much a gangbang occurs that
produces children children which will
grow up and eventually incest each other
Nova I taught you about him breeding yep
well let me to slide away what was the
point of all that bull few minutes ago
where they took Nova out of Georgia cell
and put her in a different one and leave
only to come back and take George away
to some sort of tribunal
I'm not prison bars in this scene judge
Dix as the defendants robes are stinky
and immediately is rendered naked with
no thought given to the fact that his
unwashed body might have been driving
the bulk of the stink
guy on trial is allowed to kneel steel
pen and paper and write on a message
without anyone objecting all while the
prosecutor is making his opening
arguments some makes it seems Omari Rosa
knows a great quote from the amazing
George April from his best-selling work
human farm
Helena because a horseshoe ever the
right incision shape for any kind of
surgery
but this the eights now have 20% net
success in this movie we'll practice in
a little luck they could finally get
into race on rondo territory okay guys
let's try to make this see no evil hear
no evil see no evil subtle I mean try
god damnit rot away you did the skater
series my god you made it possible for
us to expose Zira and Cornelius let's
talk about the Apes plan despite the
fact that it's much better for them to
go ahead and kill and lobotomize George
and keep the status quo they'd much
rather stage a whole trial in order to
expose to Apes they suspect don't
believe in their religion considering
the power of the council holds it's
actually amazing they couldn't just
dispose of Zira and Cornelius through
basic lies in general great I just
noticed something and I know it's taken
me a long time to get here but why'd all
the Apes were clothes jury they might
have had some sort of adamantium shame
but they live in a fucking desert and
they're covered in hair wearing jackets
and pants so look at these Apes a
lemonade pronto you just six hours to
make a full conversation
why is six that's a super strange
arbitrary number yield no matter what
else happens in this movie this ape
smoking a stogie is cool as I'll even
take a sit off for Cornelius and I have
been indicted for heresy Cornelius and
Zira who are being indicted on the
charge of general asshole Larry are
somehow able to walk around freely and
plan prison breaks shaving camp I didn't
realize that man could be monogamous
this sounds like some sort of comment on
human society but what does really mean
in the context of this movie just
because he brought one hot chick with
him doesn't mean monogamous it just
means you guys literally paired him with
the hottest woman on the planet and she
was the only one around during the
prison break there is no contradiction
between weight and shyam I probably
should remove us in for this movie
mimicking real life but let's call this
a sin of Honor and add one anyway always
giving orders just like every other
adult that's what this movie really
needed a whiny teen a full minute of
dialogue three climactic Beach cave
exploring
this thousand-year-old donk and somehow
still make noise ah withdraw a pair oh
yeah I forgot I only use the voice that
can be heard by people below me I now
need to use my above me voice I know dr.
Zaius told those two Apes to withdraw
but what's really preventing them from
coming back and doing a sneak attack on
these sitting ducks right now oh they
can't convict us of heresy you've helped
prove our innocence are you kidding me
you trust the society to accept your
evidence better follow us I'm pretty
handy with this but still did you fall
for the girl just because of proximity
back in the cages if you were ugly would
we still be seeing the same ending all
my life I have waited you're coming and
drag a geek I guess except that's what
my ex-girlfriend told me when we had sex
about two minutes our build up to a
reveal that would make ray from the
force awakens give up not gonna lie
Statue of Liberty looks pretty good for
2,000 years of wear and tear that's it
I'm going to remove five sins for one of
the best cinematic reveals ever
I mean Lani
[Applause]
[Music]
well it's gonna be a scorcher you might
be pregnant now
gotcha one jump ahead of the breadline
one swing ahead of the sword only what I
can afford
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I'm
just a kid I fell in some ice and later
got bought out by some of your
scientists oh dear dear his life then
I've only an hour to dress what are they
wearing now you will spend that hour
getting acquainted with George Bailey
[Music]
and I'll defend myself
time to run your soil texture oh wow
everybody here that I just discovered
dark